did you visualize meeting your beautiful
wife do you know what when I was when I
was driving there was this band that was
created called the Spice Girls and I had
a sponsor and they made these cakes and
they said look we've got we've entered a
license agreement with this girl band if
they sell the cakes with you know with
the spice goes on then we'll be able to
sponsor you some more money and so of
course every young kid wanted a spice
girl's birthday cake so you know
indirectly she financed my career so so
um that's not in the dossier that was
that was you know it was Destiny for us
to to to meet and and when we did meet
um she gave me a really hard time you
know she came how so she came to a race
um and uh we had two driver we had
Sebastian V and an Australian guy Mark
Weber and and when I met her she gave me
a hard time she said why it's unfair
that you guys support Sebastian so much
more because he was doing all the
winning and you know you need to give
Mark Weber the same car and I said what
have you ever thought the other guy's
just a bit better also what how does she
know about racing and what she she liked
it she liked you know she liked the
sport her car her dad was a car dealer
so she liked cars she liked speed and I
just liked her spirit I like the fact
that she's prepared to take me on and
have that she has Moxy yeah that she was
prepared to take me on and have a go so
then what what do you then she walked
off and I said look I always preferred
Baby
Spice and
um you don't have a sense of humor
that's the relationship that we have
that that you know she'll take the The
Mickey out of me I'll take the Mickey
out of her and okay so if you can't take
the Mickey out of yourself or someone
else I'd say exctly you got to be able
to laugh and you know we laugh every day
and uh it's some it's something stupid
you know Etc so uh so she took the
Mickey out of you she took the Mickey
out of herself she's cool you like her
what do you do did you call her up what
happened after that um we didn't PA
didn't cross until years and then and
then we met again you planted a seed so
we planted a planted a seed and and you
know when you you have a connection with
someone it was clear I I had a clear
connection with her and and likewise and
I knew that was the girl I wanted to
marry I'd never thought about marriage
before I'd never even contemplated but I
knew very early on that's that's the
girl I want to marry we just clicked we
just really clicked and you built this
beautiful family yeah with Bluebell and
a
and Monty yeah yeah yeah it's a blended
family but they they all get on so well
I have one too now and I've never
been so settled in my life yeah they're
friends as well as siblings and I think
that um that for me that's the most
rewarding thing is seeing you know
getting the family together having
family time that're you know most of
them are here this weekend um so I get
to be a dad on Monday and take him to
Disneyland and that kind of stuff so
taking them to Disney yeah yeah yeah I'm
doing all of that I'm going to make
Jerry where Mickey Mouse ears and and
that kind of stuff so she she's going to
she's going to love me for that okay is
it true that you have a lucky
toilet how' you know that well it was it
was fascinating to me because I always
repeat the same stall myself when I go
to a bathroom that I know it's like I
have a weird thing where I have to
repeat the same thing is that it for you
no for me it's always think I've done
since I was 12 13 years of age is it cuz
you want a race yeah it is and and I
went to that L and I thought well that
works so I'll use it again and so every
every every race it's just like a
Superstition now so every race I have a
lucky Loot and so sometime can be a bit
weird if there's like 20 toilets that
are available and you're waiting for the
one that's engaged and it's it's just
it's like a ritual now I have a few
superstitions a lucky L is almost like I
take the Mickey out of you your language
is much nicer yeah you know so the way I
approached a driver before a race and
shake his hand where I stand in the
garage before the race I have a lucky
pair of pants I'm going to frame them at
the end of my career as you
[Music]
should